americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day 114
joe biden may have turned the page we
will not 114 days now americans trap
behind enemy lines of terrorists 127
days since joe biden lied and promised
he'd leave nobody behind the media mob
the big tech mob they have all turned
the page as well and tonight in
afghanistan or the islamic emirates of
afghanistan they're now facing
widespread starvation economic collapse
a reign of terror the taliban just
tortured a man to death over a critical
facebook post some families are selling
their young daughters to taliban
fighters in order to buy food clearly no
one is safe including the americans and
u.s green card holders that joe
abandoned and military family members
make no mistake joe biden he can turn
the page all he wants but they're still
trapped behind enemy lines they see by
the way the world is watching our
enemies are all watching they see joe
biden on the world stage they see his
weakness they do not respect him they do
not fear him and that brings us to our
top story tonight and that is every
hostile actor on the world stage every
hostile regime on the world stage is now
preparing to take full advantage of the
fact that the leader of the free world
the supposed leader joe biden is weak
and in an obvious and significant
cognitive decline they all know joe has
no backbone joe has no will and joe has
no ability to protect america and the
western world's interests around the
globe and by the way now they are
looking to capitalize big time tonight
there are three very serious crises on
the horizon look at russia they are now
threatening to invade ukraine they have
a massive troop presence and deployment
right on the border china is threatening
to take over taiwan or as they call it
reunification it's a takeover
they're saying so publicly and they have
no problem all day long flying fighter
jets all over taiwan's airspace iran is
now on the verge of getting nuclear
weapons joe stupidly is just easing
sanctions as if that's going to work and
it appears most days joe biden doesn't
even know what day of the week it is
let's break this down it's very
important this could go south really
fast first according to u.s intelligence
russian dictator the hostile actor that
he is vladimir putin is now planning
what is a massive military invasion of
ukraine we have satellite images they
show somewhere between seventy thousand
and ninety four thousand russian troops
already amassed at the border around a
hundred thousand more soldiers are in
the process of being mobilized as we
speak and thanks to joe biden green
lighting russia's nordstrom 2 pipeline
while firing keystone xl
pipeline workers putin should have no
problem at all funding a large-scale
operation joe's also begging ironically
vladimir to produce more energy so we
can import it from him now with each
passing day an invasion seems inevitable
and let me say this one more time
appeasement and weakness will never work
tomorrow joe biden is planning to give
vladimir we are told a stern talking to
which undoubtedly will resolve nothing i
can tell you one thing the white house
won't do they won't put out a transcript
of what joe has to say because if they
ever did we could see how weak he really
is is there any doubts that putin is
laughing behind the scenes of joe biden
you don't think joe
is being laughed at being the cognitive
mess he is in the kremlin meanwhile
another deeply concerning international
crisis is unfolding a little closer to
home china not only is saber rattling
with taiwan they're now reportedly
attempting to establish what is their
first permanent military base on the
atlantic ocean giving china's navy navy
the ability to operate just off the east
coast of the united states and we
thought the hypersonic missile was bad
and this as china continues to ramp up
hostilities as i said against taiwan
they refused to take any responsibility
for the pandemic they unleashed on the
entire world it keeps getting worse one
new variant after another and let's not
forget about china's forced labor their
concentration camps it is now presently
modern day being used against their
minority muslim population so far
biden's only response a diplomatic
boycott of the winter olympics in china
in 2022 oh in other words tony blinken
the the weak secretary of state that he
is the pathetically weak one he's not
going to be attending the olympics this
year
president xi is laughing as well at the
cognitive mess that is joe biden which
brings us now to the third international
crisis iran sadly dangerously is closer
than ever to develop into developing a
nuclear weapon now surprise surprise
biden's polite negotiations with the
muellers in iran have fallen apart and
now the administration is asking china
and russia america's two biggest foes
help out pressure iran with us now joe
begs opec
and china and russia okay that would be
the trifecta of joe biden foreign policy
failure and of course the other option
now being weighed by joe biden just
accept a nuclear-armed iran a
nuclear-capable iran in other words
nuclear weapons in the hands of the
number one state sponsor of terror that
have this sick twisted ugly ideology of
convert or die
now joe here's an idea maybe you can
send i don't know maybe said hunter the
crack addict turned world-renowned
artist hunter biden you can send them to
china and russia and sort everything out
after all hunter's been very successful
raking in massive sums of cash from
those two countries over the years
without any relevant experience that we
can find it all and of course hunter was
selling access to his father we know
that and meanwhile we have no idea who's
shelling out what up to five hundred
thousand dollars for hunters what
portraits of a crack addict but i have a
feeling the so-called art collectors are
looking to buy more than just a terrible
painting from an amateur artist remember
hunter biden is currently under
investigation for international tax
evasion money laundering but he's a
democrat they get away with everything
the fbi reportedly in possession of
hunter's laptop from hell as miranda
devine's book points out several months
ago jen saki gladly referring to stories
surrounding hunter biden's laptop as
russian disinformation today she
couldn't be bothered to circle back on
the very important story and the lie
that she told take a look
shortly after president biden's virtual
meeting with the chinese president
her son's attorney said that he has
finally divested
from a chinese investment fund
controlled by state-owned entities i was
hoping you could commit to basic
transparency about that transaction
including the name of the buyer the
dollar amount and the timing and the
second question is my colleague miranda
devine has a new book out called
the laptop from hell and i was hoping
that you could confirm that the laptop
is indeed authentic
and not russian disinformation as you
seem to suggest on twitter last year
well on the first uh the president's son
is not an employee of the federal
government so i'd point you to his
representatives and as it relates to the
book i've never neither had the time nor
interest in exploring or reading the
book go ahead son's attorney go ahead
tina i think i answered your question go
ahead you can go to the representative
of the person who's not an employee of
the federal government go ahead tina i
think we have to move on
no i think we dodged the question and
moving on is just the convenient way of
not facing the reality of selling access
to joe biden what about tony boblinski's
charge that joe biden sat in on meetings
with let's see oh a chinese energy
company so maybe jenn saki she can
confirm that joe biden has zero conflict
of interest in china and russia and
ukraine
and she'll never answer that question
because the answer is not good
you the american people deserve better
and imagine if the last name were trump
you know in his former president trump
said over the weekend he was on with the
great one mark levin
he said let's hope it's not too late for
this great republic take a look
president obama was very divisive
but people were more quiet about it they
didn't want to insult him
but he was very divisive
but the biden
administration
is far worse
this country has tremendous potential
tremendous
but
we're giving it away and there'll be a
point
there'll be a point where the country
can't come back and we can never allow
that point to be reached hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else